bonsoir je suis vraiment ravi d'être là
et d'avoir l'opportunité de m'exprimer
de pouvoir proposer ma vision du monde
quand on m'a appelé pour me proposer de
faire c'est adx on m'a dit que c'est pas
parce que je suis comédienne n'est pas
ce que j'ai écrit des chroniques dans un
journal local
alors je ne suis pas sûr que ces
chroniques va le grand chose mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que elles me permettent de
coucher sur le papier mais réflexion mes
expériences du moment et c'est un luxe
parce que je peux les partager avec les
gens et elles me permettent aussi de
faire une mise au point de ma vision du
monde comme ses chroniques elles sont
faites par écrit
c'est un exercice qui est beaucoup plus
facile pour moi que ce que j'ai à faire
aujourd'hui avec vous parce que c'est
vrai que je suis comédienne mais je suis
comédienne pour le cinéma et c'est pas
un hasard puisque
je suis très stressée de parler devant
les gens je vous demanderais du coup de
ne pas prendre en compte les biographie
que vous avez sous les yeux parce que
quand on m'a demandé de l'écrire je
savais pas encore du tout ce dont
j'allais vous parlez et si je devais la
réécrire aujourd'hui je mettrais juste
noémie femme de 27 ans de nationalité
suisse et résidentes en france parce que
c'est vraiment tout ce qui importe dans
ce qui va suivre
quand on m'a annoncé que le thème de ce
tadic se seraient ensemble je me suis
posé mille questions comme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pour moi le vivre ensemble
comment vivre ensemble pourquoi vivre
ensemble et pourquoi est-ce que c'est
surtout si difficile je me suis rendu
compte que selon moi ce qu'ils
régissaient nos possibilités de vivre
ensemble s'articuler autour des notions
entre autres de bienveillance et de
malveillance
et alors ça paraît simple mais je me
suis attaché à noter tous les moments
dans le quotidien ou la bienveillance
fait défaut pour moi comme pour les
autres donc tous ces moments où on pense
au profit qu'on va tirer de telle ou
telle situation ou de telle ou telle
personne ces moments où on préfère ne
pas écouter ne pas entrer en empathie
avec l'autre par paresse par confort ou
par peur de devoir s'engager à donner et
à aider alors qu'on a déjà tellement
peur de manquer je me suis aussi rendu
compte que je me disais souvent à moi
même t'as pas le temps ton temps et
aussi précieux que celui de n'importe
qui t'as pas les moyens pourquoi est-ce
que t'adresse cette personne alors que
tu sais pertinemment que ne va pas aider
en retour et j'ai l'impression quand on
vit dedans une idée d'un monde où on a
l'impression que le monde est pourri que
le monde est de plus en plus rapides que
les gens sont de plus en plus
individualiste que tout est basé sur le
profit et qu'on est déjà assez absorbé
avec nos proches avec notre famille et
qu'on n'a pas le temps ni la force
d'être bienveillant avec tous les autres
tous les inconnus et c'est pour ça que
alors que moi je suis une personne qui
essaie d'être empathique et le plus
bienveillante possible dans mon
quotidien et dans ma vie avec les autres
je me demandais ce que j'allais pouvoir
vous raconter de mon rapport à la
bienveillance à la malveillance et au
vivre ensemble et vous avez de la chance
parce que cédant à la pression de devoir
faire un tedx parce que c'est une grande
chance mais c'est aussi une énorme
pression je voulais absolument me donner
une légitimité
je voulais vous raconter une histoire
incroyable d'une histoire dans tant de
laquelle je pourrais tirer une parabole
sur le vivre ensemble
donc je me suis intéressé à une statue
qui se trouve à sion dans la ville d'à
côté qui s'appelle la catherine et qui
pour moi
enfin le récit de la donation de la
statue à la ville exprimé vraiment bien
des questionnements liés à l'identité
des gens entre les cantons en suisse
alors qu'ils vivent tous ensemble dans
un même pays et vous avez vraiment la
chance parce que ma grand-mère est
décédée et il m'est arrivé une histoire
qui m'a bouleversé et qui exprime
vraiment beaucoup mieux
tous ces questionnements que j'avais
qu'ils sont liés à la bienveillance et
au vivre ensemble
j'ai envie de la partager avec vous et
j'insiste sur le fait que cette histoire
soulève des questionnements mais
n'apporte aucune réponse
donc la situation nous sommes en plein
mois d'août août dernier et j'emprunte
la voiture de ma grand-mère pour
rejoindre des copains en dordogne dans
l'ouest de la france qui ont une ferme
et qui organise une semaine de fête de
bouffe entre amis ce sont des gens qui
sont assez extraordinaire et qui
inventent qui font vivre une manière de
vivre ensemble qui est basée sur la paix
sur la joie sur
le respect la responsabilité et la
création artistique de tous les instants
alors je passe là bas trois jours
merveilleux jusqu'à la veille de la
grande fête finale qui doit se tenir
dans la forêt et ce jour là j'apprends
le décès de ma grand mère
à partir de ce moment là j'ai qu'une
envie c'est de retourner en suisse
rejoindre la famille être avec eux donc
je prends la décision de repartir tout
seul en suisse donc j'arrive là et on
enterre ma grand-mère tous ensemble
c'est très beau et je repars dans le
temps ce pour rejoindre mes potes le
soir même pour faire la fête en
l'honneur de ma grand mère
sauf que sur l'autoroute à 23h30 le
voyons ce top de ma voiture se met à
clignoter et je panique un peu et je
m'arrête dans la première station
service que je trouve
j'ouvre mon capot le moteur et les
bouillants
donc voilà je suis pas très à l'aise et
un mec qui est en train de faire le
plein qui s'approche de moi et qui
regarde mon moteur et qui m'annonce
qu'en fait j'ai plus de courroie
d'accessoires c'est très dangereux et
que je devrais plus du tout prendre le
volant
à ce moment là j'essaye de joindre mes
potes du coup dans leur ferme le
problème c'est que c'est une femme qui
est vraiment perdu dans la campagne il
ya vraiment zéro réseau donc impossible
de les joindre
donc j'essaie d'atteindre l'assurance et
je me rends compte que ma grand mère n'a
pas renouvelé le contrat d'assurance
donc que le contrat est périmé et que je
ne suis pas du tout assuré ailleurs
qu'en suisse
donc je me pose je réfléchis donc il
fait nuit il est tard la station-service
souvent des chips mais pas du tout deux
coureurs d'accessoires et puis il ya pas
mal de gens qui zone est un gars qui
s'approche de moi qui me dit
mademoiselle vous êtes en panne vous
inquiétez pas vous pouvez venir dormir
chez moi donc je dis non merci ça va je
me débrouillais ça valait vraiment mais
bon je commence un peu angoissé quand
même et un deuxième gars qui arrivent et
qui me dit non mais bien dans ma voiture
je t'amène là où tu devrais aller il n'y
a pas de souci et j'ai vraiment pas du
tout envie de m'enfermer dans avec
quelqu'un dans une voiture donc je dis
pareil non merci ça va aller et ouais je
me sens de plus en plus mal
en vérité et un troisième gars qui
s'avance et
je me prépare déjà à être assez fermé à
lui dire t'inquiète je gère pas de souci
a besoin de toi et le gars il est grand
il a une tête un probable franchement il
fait flipper il a l'air atteint de
poliomyélite donc en fait ses bras sont
atrophiés et il vient boire il dit ouais
je vais dépanner ta voiture pas de souci
et tout est alors honnêtement il me
paraît vraiment être pas du tout la
personne indiquée dans ma situation et
en plus pour couronner la situation du
coup il ya son pote qui arrive derrière
et qui est plus petit que lui mais qui
est deux fois plus musclée et qui lui
carrément ouvre mon capot et commence à
farfouiller dans mon moteur sans ma
permission quoi et vraiment j'insiste je
leur dis non non je veux pas dead tout
va bien et il força situation et il se
présente alors il s'appelle hadj et
jamel et ils ont un pote qui est mécano
et qui va arriver qui va m'amener des
cours à d'accessoires et tous qui va
m'aider
qui va me dépanner bon j'ai pas vraiment
d'autre solution alors même si je suis
quand même vraiment vraiment pas du tout
à l'aise je me dis ben j'attends
je vois puis je veux pas non plus entre
en conflit avec quoi parce que je suis
pas super assurés quoi là il ya le gars
qui m'avait proposé de monter dans sa
voiture qui revient et qui veut
absolument me dépanner à son tour donc
il arrive et puis moi je suis avec donc
ces deux à jamel qui quand ils me voient
qu'il ya un autre gars qui essaient de
me dépanne il ils lui disent non mais
nous on s'occupe d'elle n'y a pas de
souci
non enfin en fait il dit ils
maintiennent leur position de
bienveillance envers moi du coup ça
éveille la méfiance de l'autre et
l'autre qui maintient sa position de
bienveillance en tout cas supposé envers
moi ça éveille la méfiance des deux
autres et donc tout le monde se méfie de
tout le monde
moi je me méfie des 3es et voilà le gars
il comprend un peu la situation il me
donne son numéro et me dit rappelle moi
au cas où si tu as un souci pas de souci
donc il me laisse là à ce moment là il
est deux heures du matin la voiture est
à moitié des montées je suis tout seul
toujours j'ai toujours pas réussi à
joindre mes potes et j'ai pas vraiment
de solution et là tout d'un coup miracle
une voiture arrive et c'est l'ami
mécanos qui arrivent et qui sort tout
son matos qui a quinze coureurs
d'accessoires de tailles différentes qui
met ma voiture sur le cric qui se met
deux sous la voiture et qui commence à
réparer mon moteur avec deux lamelles du
coup les deux ils sont à fond et ils ont
l'air de galérer ils ont l'air ça a pas
l'air d'être simple mais comme il parle
en arabe entre eux je comprends pas
vraiment tous les tenants et
aboutissants de la réparation voire même
de la situation qui est qui et à est en
fait le truc que je me disais mais
qu'est ce qu'ils vont me demander en
échange de tout ce temps et je suis une
femme et c'est compliqué quoi et
et voilà bon ben on attend la réparation
prend du temps à un moment donné un à
qui se blesse je me dis c'est un
cauchemar en fait il commence à saigner
tout fonderie est à 4 heures du matin le
mécano ressort de sous la voiture de ma
grand-mère et me dit en fait c'est mort
ta pompe à eau est cassé j'arrive pas à
remplacer la courroie donc tu peux pas
prendre son volant
c'est foutu quoi et il me dit mais donne
moi tes clés je vais prendre la voiture
je vais l'amener dans mon garage situé à
la récupérer la semaine prochaine et à
jamel ils disent mais c'est parfait
comme ça tu viens avec nous et nous on
t'emmène là où tu dois aller et moi je
leur dit non mais en fait la ferme de
mes copains elle à 300 kilomètres d'ici
elle est enfin ça représente un voyage
de six heures aller retour pour vous
donc enfin c'est compliqué quand même
ils me disent ah non non pas de soucis
voit pas tester la toute seule de toute
façon donc vient on monte dans la
voiture
voilà donc à ce moment là sam ont lâché
un peu mal à l'aise et il me semblerait
légitime que je refuse de me retrouver
dans la voiture de ses deux inconnus et
pourtant j'ai dit oui parce que à ce
moment là on était ensemble et c'est
difficile à expliquer mais en fait j'ai
été persuadés de leur bienveillance
absolue la question que je me pose c'est
comment j'ai pu en être aussi persuadé
alors il ya d'un côté je me disais bon
ça fait 3 heures qui sont en train de
travailler sur ma voiture donc s'il
avait voulu me faire du mal
il aurait déjà fait et d'un autre côté
je me disais quand on tombe sur des fous
on tombe sur des fous est en fait j'en
sais rien et une fois que je me
retrouverais enfermé avec eux dans la
voiture je pourrai plus rien faire
donc j'essaye d'écouter mon instinct et
je sais pas j'avais comme l'impression
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui les
avait mis sur ma route et je me demande
aussi dans quelle mesure cette certitude
là me donner une attitude qui leur a
permis de me prendre en charge parce que
si je m'étais vraiment méfié
la rencontre ne se serait pas fait et en
même temps on entend plein d'histoires
de gens qui se méfie pas du tout et pour
qui ça se termine en drame
et je constate qu'il est vraiment
difficile de traduire les le message des
antennes que notre cerveau et notre
corps nous met à disposition dans ces
moments là et
surtout qu'à ce moment là j'arrive enfin
à atteindre mes potes et que je leur dis
pas de souci j'arrive avec deux gars que
j'ai rencontrés dans une station service
qui vont me ramener et là mes potes ils
paniquent et surtout mon copain il me
dit mais tu ne montrent pas un cette
voiture alors ils pouvaient pas venir me
chercher parce que c'était une fête du
coup peut pas prendre le volant mais
mieux dit et picasso on en était à 3
heures deux autres il me dit non on ne
monte pas dans la voiture je t'en
supplie quoi et pourtant je fais le
choix de l'ensemble à ce moment là je
lui dit ne t'inquiète pas fais moi
confiance
bon donc je donne les clés aux mécanos
je monte dans la voiture de à jamel et
on part donc de bordeaux à quatre heures
du matin et la route est vraiment très
longue et interminable et nos mondes
sont vraiment très différent alors
on se confronte on discute on
on papote moi je suis épuisé parfois je
pique du nez je me réveille ils ont le
smile
il me regarde le soleil se lever sur la
campagne
je trouve ça trop beau moi aussi c'est
assez c'est assez beau en fait et on
arrive à 7 heures du matin dans la ferme
de mes potes et tous mes copains sont en
train de terminer leur soirée lille et
voilà sept heures du matin quoi ou
qu'ils aient lucine de me voir arriver
avec ces deux personnages ses deux anges
gardiens qui n'ont pas du tout des
physiques dans ce cas d'ange gardien et
on leur dit ben merci quoi merci merci
tel merci une bière un café rester avec
nous on passe la journée ensemble
non mais pas du tout on a des enfants il
faut qu'on y aille on leur a promis de
les emmener à la plage c'est dimanche
aujourd'hui il est 7h faut qu'on y aille
on a trois heures de route
enfin la vie continue quoi et là je me
dis vraiment rien pour hier rien pour
demain et tout pour aujourd'hui et
l'histoire pourrait s'arrêter là et les
leçons pourrait être tir de la met
comme la vie continue j'ai fini par
récupérer ma voiture à bordeaux une
semaine plus tard et à jamel insiste
pour venir me chercher avec mon copain à
l'aéroport il nous amène chez rage qui
vit dans un une pièce de cité bordelaise
extrêmement modeste extrêmement mal
aménagé au vu de son handicap il nous
propose un café la machine à café elle
explose le il explose de rire ils se
mettent à la réparer le mécano arrive
avec ma la voiture de ma grand mère
ils me montrent les réparations elles
sont nickel et la mdi voilà je te
demande quand même 200 euros et moi ça
me paraît mais dérisoire au vu du fait
qu'il a changé deux pièces dans ma
voiture qu'il a passé trois heures à
essayer de la réparer sur une station
service un samedi soir après sa journée
de travail
et qui l'a gardé ça va ma voiture
pendant une semaine dans son garage et
hadj il se met à négocier le prix à dire
que c'est trop cher il dit non non non
tu dois pas payer trop cher c'est pas du
tout les prix jeudi messi mais bien sûr
c'est l'aimer à temps mais c'est pas
cher du tout je suis mes gars gêné et en
plus vous m'avez déjà fait une tonne de
cadeaux est imminent si doc nous a fait
un cadeau tu nous a fait confiance et
nous dans notre monde dans notre société
en fait ça nous arrive jamais et il nous
laisse reprendre la route
alors avec mon copain on est à moitié
malaise ramon était émerveillé de cette
leçon de bienveillance sans aucune
contrepartie en plus qu'un appel sur la
route pour les rassurer
ils nous demandent rien d'autre et donc
pendant les cinq heures de route que
dure le trajet jusqu'à paris on est on
est vraiment happé par une remise en
question sur nous-mêmes alors sur nos a
priori sur nos doutes sur notre
bienveillance et sur notre propre
malveillance qui d'entre nous aurait
fait ce qu'ils aient ce qu'ils ont fait
et qui donne quoi et pour quoi et à qui
à qui donne ton personnellement et en
tant que société en tant qu'ensemble
justement comment expliquer leur
reconnaissance que je leur ai fait
confiance alors que eux mêmes ont donné
ce que personne d'autre n'aurait donné
et alors que eux-mêmes possède six peut
en tout cas du pain matériellement
parlant comment être à la hauteur de
leur générosité de tant de bonne humeur
de solutions comment comment réussir à
faire circuler cette énergie cette
espèce de secret qu'ils détiennent et
qui les rend beaucoup plus riche que
tous les risques que j'ai pu croiser
voilà et tout ça me pousse à vous dire
que je crois que les interactions
humaines qui sont basés sur l'argent et
sur le profit ne sont pas la seule
possibilité que la croyance capitaliste
qu'il faut un prêté pour un rendu que
tout est basé sur le profit qu'il faut
tirer avantage des situations s'écroule
devant l'exemple concret que je vous
livre ici il ya d'autres modèles
possibles
et comme quoi il est parfois important
de se retrouver démunis pas forcément
matériellement mais comme moi par
exemple à court de solution donc démunis
pour pour être plus en phase avec le
monde tel qu'il est dans toutes ces
réalités parce que ce monde est injuste
il est cruel et inégale avec énormément
de gens et pourtant ces mêmes gens sont
capables de vous redonner la force de
croire en la bienveillance parce qu'il
la pratique
concrètement et donc ils rendent concret
un discours qu'on emprunte tous mais
qu'on oublie vraiment souvent
[Applaudissements]